[Music]
name a movie this man's probably been in
it to be very honest with you quiz show
he'd contact Armageddon perfect storm
Black Hawk Down crash The Longest Yard
remake just to name a few he's on mom
currently on CBS he is also the director
and co-writer and one of the stars of
the film Colebrook in theaters on demand
and digital that's today William
Fichtner here on the rich guys to show
good to see you sir good to see you too
all right let's get we'll get to your
movie and we'll get to your movies sure
but let's get to your Buffalo Bill let's
just talk about it because you are a
die-hard Bills fan from where are you
from originally were born along I'll
miss you field Air Force Base okay at
two months old my mother said to my
father we are moving back to my hometown
of Buffalo okay so I it's it's all
Buffalo it's all Buffalo I learned how
to drive in the parking lot of the
stadium when they were building it come
on now oh that's where the we're the
other driving instructors you know for
all the kids take your driver's ed yeah
right to the parking lot that's when
they were building the stadium we were
watching them two sides go up and that's
where I learned how to drive so it's
it's it's kind of like in a way maybe
learning I'm driving an obstacle course
because I imagine did somebody try to
body slam through a taste not while you
were learning I don't have enough beef
on Wix in a few libet's and you're on
tables what can I tell you have you done
the parking lapse
yes I have okay I went to I still tell
this story early 90s when the pills were
actually pretty good yes they were they
I went to a playoff game I think it was
the Jets I know it was freezing outside
and I remember from where I parked in
the parking lot to get in I passed 2
pigs on Spitz and we're talking January
where it's like Sub Zero of two right
just in the way that I walked it's it's
incredibly festive
I mean did
is one way to describe the Buffalo Bill
apartment parking lot seen before a game
we we've been there on occasion for the
NFL Network over the last 15 16 years
and the the the fan base is beyond over
the moon about their team in this year
in particular it just feels like Josh
Allen's the right guy do you feel that
way or have you gone there yet I
absolutely feel that way and and with
that said you know there's still a
learning curve you know I I feel like
the Bills have yet this year to have
four unbelievable quarters but they're
winning games having two and a half
right you know but I'm looking forward
to that game when it's four quarters and
a lot of it you know is is a learning
curve and you know I mean you look at
Josh's stats I think he's you know he
has the best you know completion
percentage I think in the NFL in the
fourth quarter but we got to get to the
fourth quarter and be in the game and
and he's had a few come from behind
already this year in the fourth quarter
so I am a believer but the thing that
I'm waiting for I said this to my son
this morning just this morning you know
what I really want I want that 350 yard
game for Josh because it hasn't come yet
and when it happens I think it'll I
think it'll just like free him right he
did finally break that stretch right
that where their non 300 yard games he
did have one where and Kelly was in the
building and Jim loves him too you know
like he feels like he's he's he's but I
don't want to I don't want to I'll just
go there it doesn't seem like there's a
trend Edwards here situation right like
you're not having a false belief that
this kid actually is the real deal you
know well you know what if he's not
doing it in the air mm-hmm any season
opening I mean that's the one thing that
nobody talked about with Josh when he
was coming there if he takes off nobody
did you're right and the truth about it
is when he takes off I remember a couple
of plays last year and I'm sure the
coaching staff every time he takes off
or like oh don't write please don't run
right I've seen linebackers go after him
and they don't catch him mm-hmm he'd you
know he came motor and he's a big guy
but this year you'll notice that he'll
slide well at least William Fichtner
here on the on the Rich Eisen show at
least you know Brady wasn't in league
yet when you worked with Affleck on
Armageddon right I mean cuz no but he
was he talking about New England at the
time or is your Buffalo guy or some
people in New England talk about New
England a lot Hey true story yes
1998 and I'm working on this film might
have been mm mm working on his film
called what's the worst that could
happen when I was shooting in Boston
this Danny DeVito and all that all the
Teamsters guys around it and and great
guys and we talk every day sports and
they just couldn't stop talking about
the Yankees this is before Boston went
on a sweet little run in the 2000s yes
couldn't stop talking about it sports
radio can't stop talking about the
Yankees one day I looked at all these
guys and I said I hate to tell you this
but they're not really talking about you
guys in news they're not it's really
it's really a you thing you know 27
whatever it was at the time but Boston's
Boston's great sports I know bottom line
you know there's been a they've been
spiking the football and more than just
other sports you know he's a Boston guy
over there yeah I'm now looking over
there did you did you marry it did I
hear you married into it Boston sports
fan you could say that I did Terry into
that I did I married into from Worcester
and and it's it's all Patriots oh so on
the weekends you know there's there's
two nice TVs in the house and one's
nicer than the other so I look at my 17
year old son on my let's have a
democratic vote it's Anna Kimmy you're
coming downstairs
just voted for that she goes you want
dinner tonight I'm going upstairs
William Fichtner here on the Rich Eisen
show well you know that's amazing that
you're your diehard Buffalo but so who's
your guy growing up who is your pill fan
growing up who's your mom playerwise
yeah who is your guy I love Steve Tasker
I just I just said you know I mean I
loved everything about that team in
Bruce Smith and and
I was really younger you know I mean you
know that was back in jack kemp de jour
when Daryle Lamonica was the back up at
the old rock pile yeah and I remember
going to games there with my dad and but
you know is it developed a lake chill
Ferguson joke cribs over the years nice
but there was something about Tasker
that you know arguably maybe the
smallest guy in the field and every time
I know special teams half half those
kickoffs you know he'd get the tackle he
was amazing he just fly through people
over people I just thought wow I just
want to do things in life like Steve
Tasker plays football you know a lot of
people have mentioned that he if they do
finally put just a pure special teams
player not a punter not a kicker but the
guy who just titles or returns that he'd
be a hall-of-famer
yeah thief Tasker no doubt about it no
doubt about it he was unbelievable okay
I love it so let's talk about your film
Colebrook before we go down a little bit
of memory lane with your filmography you
wrote it you co-wrote it and you
directed it tell people of what it's
about essentially and why you decided to
make this film well you know the whole
thing really began for Colebrook in 2001
I spent five months in Rabat Morocco
working on Black Hawk Down mm-hmm and I
met two of my all-time best friends on
that film it's not like you don't meet
great people along the way
but this particular film in Morocco
together Eric Bana kim coates the three
of us buddies for life came back to LA
Coates lives you know half an hour to
ten minutes from where I live and I went
to another good friend of mine came
Devore and I said you know what I got an
idea for a story but it's something I
want to write to do with Kim and so we
really all began there and then started
putting this this story together about
two two guys in a small town I set it in
Cortland New York south of Syracuse and
two ordinary guys that have this
extraordinary experience and ultimately
are faced with this decision of how far
do you go to help a stranger I wanted I
wanted a story with that had meaning to
it and and and a journey of two guys and
you know how do you find your best self
and out of that came you know it didn't
start off
way but something that was had a lot of
historical significance of of how this
story developed but you know it really
developed just in in in in the process
and all of a sudden five or six years
after working on and we looked at each
other and said I think we got a story
that we could show some people and let's
try to raise some money and 13 years ago
I've been looking for this date today
no kidding yeah that today would be the
day that it would see the light of day
because the truth about it is what you
know just to make a film even if it
works for an indie film there's no
guarantee you're ever gonna get to a
movie screen so I'm mighty grateful well
congratulations on that I mean the way
that uh how long it takes for something
to get made yeah to put it all together
exactly and I'm gonna I you know I work
as you said earlier work on this show
mom yep
so we do the live shows on Friday night
I told my wife it's playing here in LA
at the Lumley playoffs in Pasadena I
said you're gonna go with all our
friends because I'm getting on a red-eye
and I don't take red eyes and I'm going
to Buffalo this weekend I'm gonna
introduce that film kim coates is
already there I told him I said I'm
going to Buffalo he goes oh you're gonna
have a great time I said no no it's so
are you so you're going a day before me
so you can go talk to people I'm gonna
meet him tomorrow he's picking me up at
the airport and we're gonna introduce
the film all weekend - back in your
hometown yeah right back birddog began
unfortunately the bills are in Cleveland
this weekend that's why people are gonna
come and see the movie hopefully that's
why I'm gonna go and see the movie
Sunday afternoon well you should check
it out Colebrook again in theaters on
demand and digital today it's been a
long time coming for William Fichtner
okay let's get into some of these films
what I could just feel when you're in
heat on that in that film and DeNiro
tells you that it isn't a dead man and
the other end of the line yeah
do you even just hearing that or or
knowing that it's DeNiro delivering that
line actually have a sense of fear
William in actor well you know what I
remember I remember that when we did
that part of the scene just I was in New
York and they said we're gonna call you
about three o'clock in the morning and
and the phone will ring
stay off the phone I said don't worry
about three o'clock in the morning the
phone's gonna ring it's De Niro and
we're gonna record the scene mm-hmm
so of course I'd get it and De Niro's
like you know there's a dead on the
other end of his line right and I'm and
I'm sitting there thinking it's one of
my first movies come on a phone in
between takes how you doing mr. De Niro
yeah good okay all right
and Michael Mann how many times did he
make you do it oh I don't know if you've
if you're mentioning that because
there's some other thing you heard yes
but I remember it was first day of
photography mm-hmm so you get a 7:00
a.m. call you figure you're gonna go to
seven eight o'clock at night yes then
they go the next day
first day of photography three o'clock
in the morning
come on day one I'm standing there I
walked over to Michael Mann I said mr.
Mann he could call me Michael I said
Michael is there anything else you want
me to try and he said no why I said cuz
because we're on take 26 and I didn't
know if you wanted me to try something
else you said no no no I got it on the
first couple let's go again it's like
one of my first films I'm thinking I
don't know what I'm doing right or wrong
here but just go with the flow dude but
with the flow I saw it recently playing
around late at night on cable right oh
my god I look like I'm 12 years old yeah
I mean you have been in some amazing
films William you have been in some
amazing movies how did you prepare I'm
you just mentioned Black Hawk Down
before how did you prepare for that film
well that was it does Jerry Bruckheimer
films so would you know Jerry
Bruckheimer you got to think that the US
military loves Jerry Bruckheimer making
films like Top Gun and Armageddon and so
that he gets he gets DoD approval I'm
sure Department of Defense yes and so
what they did one Blackhawk down the
that 24 like 22 year olds that played
Rangers yes
they went to Fort Benning in Georgia
which is where the Ranger school is
and they got to go to classrooms and
they showed him all this stuff me
eric bana nikolai waldo from game of
thrones kim coates wasn't with us yet we
went to Fort Bragg in North Carolina
Fayetteville and it was like III I liken
it to like fantasy baseball camps where
you goin you play with like the pros and
you get that experience we got there
they I don't know if I could say that I
am saying this they took us out on the
field and they said this is a grenade
launcher mm-hmm and there's some trees
over here
so go ahead launch it and then we had a
day that we dead was like det-cord
where they put it on doors now these
guys were with us these guys are special
service guys yes they were training us
for the film but they were really giving
us the full experience and it was
amazing and you know what came out of
that was not only such a respect for
these guys and and you know part of the
reason that they really jumped in there
is because a lot of the guys that were
lost in Somalia came out of there out of
the out of Fort Bragg and Special Forces
school and all of those guys during that
week you know kept looking at us and
saying get it right and by the time we
left there what all the love and support
they gave us you know it was in our
hearts and minds that we wanted to get
it right William Fichtner here in the
Rich Eisen show what about perfect storm
did you spend a considerable amount of
time and New England for that one or on
a boat or on a ship or what have you we
spent a little bit of time down in Dana
Point cuz you know go five miles out
point the camera together we could be
anywhere now you can't you can't go out
on the ocean in the middle of a storm
because of obvious things so stage 16
when you're driving down Barham and you
see Warner Brothers yes and you see the
big symbol on the stage that stage 16
apparently underneath the floorboards is
when is that there was an attack there
like a 90 by 90 foot 24 feet deep tank
yes
I rumor had it it's where they used to
do some Esther Williams musicals like
way back in the day well they filled up
that tank and they made a replica of the
Andrea Gail put it on again
you know hydraulic machine and we shot
in there all green screen okay so we
would go in the morning and that's where
we did two two and a half months of the
storm sequence we would get there in the
morning and all the other actors on it
used to tease me and go hey Billy you
got your wristbands on and your
Dramamine because you have a breakfast
burrito in the parking lot and go hop on
that thing and they get it rocking and
rolling I do believe I was the only one
that didn't throw who was the one who
led the the casting no clay was just see
his breakfast or something like that the
whole time but I do recall that
everybody you know but not you had not
not me and last one for you here let's
put up the photograph from Longest Yard
remake here now you're playing and you
look very cold Beasley like I got to be
honest with you right there number 19 on
the screen I'll take the cold these you
can look at it right there did you have
any Michael Irvin stories you got
anything from the set there my guy
Michael or anybody else
I am absolutely gonna avoid that subject
wasn't 100% no but I will tell you this
much
Sean Salsbury was there okay and he was
like our coach trainer
yeah and for the quarterbacks and my
shoulder herd for two years after that
come on now oh yeah I mean at the time
when we shot longest chart I had to have
been in mid late 40s okay so uh you know
there's a reason why I started throwing
the ball mid late forties Brady aside
yes but not being a quarterback ever
before my life and and that arm throwing
motion in that okay I was tough so
interesting you could tell Salsbury
stories but not Michael Irvin stories
William Howe for the Cowboys gentlemen
hey no no it's not that it's not that
it's just you know it's not it's not a
cowboy they was right he's a great guy
he is a great guy yes so you think he
stole Herman's helmet is that what
you're saying is that I don't even know
it's somebody somebody told that stuff
did you ever see the thing that for
Falls a buffalo you voiced
right that's a beautiful 13 area brother
talk about I think they addressed the
helmet thing that is a great I mean if
I'm not mistaken Luke Russert was the
one who put that the other you know and
it yes that is a excellent
34:30 narrated that you know he's real
homage to the City of Buffalo and so
I'll never forget that scene in there
when when they did the parade after
losing the first Superbowl and they're
on the steps of City Hall and the crowd
starts chanting for Scott Norwood to
come up and Scott Norwood
terrified because he missed you know
wide right against the Giants but the
crowd wants to see him and in in this is
late January early February it's 20
degrees outside and they're cheering his
name to get up to the mic all the bills
in the background and Marv levy are all
in tears and Buffalo was just going to
worry about it man will get them next
year
that's Buffalo it sure is man hey this
has been a lot of fun thanks for coming
on here my pleasure you'll appreciate it
everybody should check out Colebrook in
theaters on demand and digital today
it's been a long time coming for William
Fichtner for you to to see it and enjoy
it right now I now say how to Nick the
car for me they're on the set of mom in
about an hour and I love that guy guys
who knew there's this big Buffalo Bills
connection on the set of my love it one
of the stars in the showrunner a mom
Nick back I push I love him man say hi
to him well do you got it we're back
with more setting up shop in our number
three Josh Lucas and studio Chris
Brockman's news updating your phone
calls and more for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
under red TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app